es la mayor quiebra bancaria desde la
crisis financiera de 2008 el silicon
Valley Bang uno de los mayores
prestamistas en el mundo de las nuevas
empresas tecnológicas quebró el viernes
provocando una sacudida toda la
industria Empezando por sus clientes
estoy más que sorprendido estoy
conmocionado la realidad es que el
dinero está bloqueado y los fondos
pueden llegar a perderse se supone que
un banco es uno de los lugares más
seguros con los que se puede trabajar el
banco silicon Valley era el patrón oro
en cuanto a startups empresas
tecnológicas y capitalistas de riesgo
los reguladores se apresuraron a
confiscar los activos del décimo sexto
banco más grande del país la corporación
Federal estadounidense de seguro de
depósitos o fdic protege a la gente
contra la pérdida de sus depósitos en
caso de quiebra de su banco La retirada
masiva de dinero por parte de los
depositantes esta semana fue la gota que
derramó el vaso y desencadenó la quiebra
del svb y algunos señalan a la reserva
Federal por las subidas de los tipos de
interés pero la Casa Blanca ha expresado
su confianza en los reguladores
financieros nuestra secretaría del
tesoro Está siguiendo de cerca los
acontecimientos con el silicon es que
nuestro sistema bancario se encuentra en
una situación fundamentalmente distinta
a la de hace una década Así que
confiamos plenamente en nuestros
reguladores el FBI c ha dicho que todos
los clientes tendrán pleno acceso a sus
depósitos asegurados a más tardar el
lunes por la mañana pero es un duro
golpe que hizo caer las acciones
estadounidenses el viernes